company gfinity will run the tournament
which we broadcast live on Sky Sports
Wow she finishes executive chairman Gary
cook joins me now from Manchester Gary
very good evening to you what's gonna be
different about this competition for the
ones you run already
hello well as you know gfinity is is
sort of the tournament operator and to
do that you've got to be able to design
an online competition that enables
millions and millions of people to play
you've got to execute that you've got to
then host a final and so that's the role
that will play in in in this and and as
you well know FIFA is one of the one of
the world's games that's played by
million seven point seven million people
are playing it only in the UK the great
thing about that thirty percent of them
are female and 65 percent of them under
the age of 28 so this is a great step
for the Premier League I applaud them
for taking this step this is a huge
community there are over 2.2 billion
people in the gaming world and this is
this is a big step for them the Premier
League clubs at clubs themselves going
to run the qualifiers or will you do
that now we do all of the infrastructure
management we manage all of that I think
you really should try and think of us as
a virtual stadium you know we we've got
the referees we've got the assistant
referees we've got the halftime
entertainment even and so every club
will seek to identify a player some
already have players but most will use
the online competition there'll be three
rounds in beginning in December and as
we sort through that then they'll go
into a qualification and they'll be a
playoff culminating in the final in
March in our Definity arena in London
and of course this is a this is a dream
whereby somebody can play for their team
and lift the trophy on behalf of their
team and it's a compelling compelling
proposition as you mentioned Gary some
of the Premier League clubs already have
professional gamers on their books I
think Man City is one West Ham is
another don't they start with an unfair
advantage here
are you going to have to cede it to give
the other clubs a chance no well I think
what we do know is that with with you
know like as I said 7.7 million players
playing Fifa in United Kingdom there are
some stars out there there are some
people out there that are just dying to
have this opportunity to try and compete
against the best
isn't that what sport is all about after
all so I think what we're going to find
is as we as we go through the
competition we're going to create a
larger community trying to play for
their team and then they'll get to the
playoffs where the the teams who already
have players will will enter the fray
but I I think we see an awful lot of
professional players in but I think
there's an awful lot more talent out
there so this is one way that we're
going to find that talent